you guys say good morning my brother
Hank real quickly just say on three good
morning Hank it's uh what is today sure
that works okay one two three oh god I'm
so tired but I'm going to make this
video anyway because I cannot afford to
get punished again so right back to
Australia in Melbourne I was at the
amazing reading matters conference and
these outlandish ly good actors
performed a series of scenes from Paper
Towns we went to Sydney here we are in
beautiful Sydney Australia a city named
after our mother where they really like
Harry Potter it's a Yeti foot I don't
know what Australians call this but
Sarah and I call it the tree feed roll
that's why we brought the umbrella today
it's hard to tell if these guys hate
each other or if they really really like
each other
infinite me hey hey guess what job I
wouldn't do for a million dollars an
hour that one
so this warship here at the National
Maritime Museum seems to be called the
HMAS vampire
I'm telling you Hank do not mess with
Australia's Navy they will drink your
blood and we went to the aquarium where
we saw duck-billed platypuses which
reminded me that evolution can do
extraordinary things speaking of which
hey evolution where is my puppy sized
elephant more on that in a moment
I also got to see a dugong I don't know
why that guy's so fat when all he eats
is lettuce maybe it's because he also
has a brother who comes up with crazily
fatty punishments he's like when did the
door open I know when the door opens I
get food I noticed that many of you are
filtering this event through the medium
of video that's great that means that
later you can go home and actually enjoy
what happens
that you're gonna like you can't enjoy
it now but you'll be played but you're
gonna be like oh that was nice and I got
to meet hundreds of nerdfighters
including Natalie aka communitychannel
oh man Hank I was so excited to meet
communitychannel plus I got to meet
frezz Ned look who's here it's Tom hey
how's it going why doesn't he make
videos anymore
I think video games now I want you to
make videos hey I'll make me some videos
and I finally got to meet our secret
Australian family the kiddos so at the
melbourne nerdfighter gatherings debbie
warmed up the crowd with the happy dance
song
and then Nathalie and Calvin sang about
puppy-sized elephants Hank I hope that
you have recently had your cute vaccine
because otherwise this might kill you
[Music]
nerdfighters in Australia thanks for
making my visit down under so awesome
nerdfighters you can still vote on my
punishment but it looks like the
sandwich is winning at the moment so
Hank it seems likely that you'll see me
eating a fat sandwich on Tuesday